nouvelle vidéo nouveau format premier
épisode de la série carnet de santé dans
laquelle on va parler de personnalité de
gens célèbres sous l'angle de leur santé
et de comment elle a influencé leur vie
leur vie personnelle bien sûr mais aussi
leur vie professionnelle ou leur art
leur œuvre comme aujourd'hui puisqu'on
commence avec Frida Kahlo et vous allez
voir qu'il y a des trucs à dire je
reviens
[Musique]
avant de commencer à feuilleter le
carnet de santé de Frida Kahlo ensemble
laissez-moi vous parler de notre
partenaire cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par Camby cambli c'est des cours
d'anglais en visio avec des profs dont
c'est la langue maternelle je vous
explique un peu comment ça marche vous
prenez un abonnement vous planifiez
votre cours ça peut être un cours
collectif ou un cours individuel et
alors du cours et ben vous vous
connectez sur le site de combi ensuite
vous avez juste à trouver votre tuteur
et à l'appeler voilà moi là par exemple
je prends un cours avec Neil qui vit en
Angleterre bon c'est pas des cours
théoriques c'est des discussions autour
de différentes thématiques nous par
exemple on a parlé de bouffe et de
comment bien manger le principe c'est ça
en fait on discute on pratique l'anglais
on se décomplexe parce que je sais pas
vous mais moi je suis pas toujours à
l'aise pour parler anglais avec des gens
qui parlent bien la langue et puis bien
sûr quand on se trompe ou qu'on vue sur
un mot bah le tuteur nous explique ce
qu'il faut dire voilà donc c'est
rassurant parce que bah tu es dans ton
élément moi par exemple j'étais dans mon
salon j'ai bien accroché avec mes hommes
et on a parlé une demi-heure sans que je
sois gêné donc si vous avez envie de
vous dérouiller ou de vous décoincer
genre si vous prévoyez un voyage que
vous avez besoin de parler anglais pour
le boulot ou que vous avez un date avec
quelqu'un qui parle pas français et bah
n'hésitez pas en plus évidemment j'ai un
petit cadeau je vous offre une réduction
de 50% sur les abonnements de 12 mois en
cours particulier ou en groupe c'est
comme vous voulez en gros ça vous fait
des cours d'anglais à partir de 14,50 €
par mois voilà donc si vous avez envie
d'améliorer votre niveau d'anglais sans
bouger de chez vous ou de n'importe où
que vous soyez d'ailleurs et n'importe
quand parce que c'est 7 jours sur 7 et
24 heures sur 24 et bah cliquez sur le
lien que je vous ai mis dans la
description et let's go
c'est de l'anglais j'ai pris des cours
alors Frida Kahlo Frida Kahlo c'est un
peu comme Che Guevara ou Guns N' Roses
tout le monde en a entendu parler
visuellement si tu très bien il y a
plein de gens qui l'ont sur leurs
t-shirt mais qui savent pas forcément ce
que c'est donc on va parler un peu de
Magdalena Frida Carmen Kahlo Calderon de
son complet
j'ai pas pris de cours d'espagnol par
contre elle est née le 6 juillet 1907 au
Mexique même si elle prétendra plus tard
être né le 7 juillet 1910 pas par
coquetterie c'est parce que c'est la
date de la révolution mexicaine et ça
c'est déjà un symbole qui en dit pas mal
sur Frida Kahlo la révolté et sur sa vie
faite de combat dès qu'on va contre tout
ce qui a servi un dictateur les
stéréotypes liées aux genres on va en
parler un petit peu plus tard mais aussi
la maladie le handicap et la douleur et
pour les derniers exemples on peut dire
qu'elle sait de quoi elle parle donc
c'est ces combats qui vont nourrir son
œuvre oui parce que son métier c'est pas
de vendre des t-shirts son métier c'est
d'être artiste peintre mais revenons-en
à son carnet de santé tout commence et
bah dès sa naissance en fait puisque
Frida Kahlo naît avec ce qu'on appelle
un spina-bifina on en est pas
complètement sûr à vrai dire mais si on
fouine un peu on trouve quand même
plusieurs personnes comme on parlait un
spinnabifida c'est une anomalie
congénitale de la colonne vertébrale en
gros pendant la grossesse il y a un truc
qui s'appelle le tube neural qui est
censé de fermer sauf que là il se
referme pas correctement et du coup la
moelle épinière elle est pas protégée
comme il faut parfois ça forme une
espèce de boule entourée par une
membrane qui peut sortir à l'extérieur
au niveau du dos ou pas mais surtout ça
cause un certain nombre de trucs cool
comme des problèmes de sensibilité des
paralysies et des douleurs voilà comment
la petite Frida débute dans la vie et
c'est pas terminé parce que six ans plus
tard elle contracte une autre maladie
pas une anomalie congénitale du coup
cette fois mais une maladie infectieuse
la polio la polio c'est un peu comme
Frida Kahlo Che Guevara et Guns N'Roses
tout le monde en a déjà entendu parler
mais il y a pas grand monde qui sait
vraiment ce que c'est par contre
personne ne porte de t-shirt polo
ok j'ai rien dit la polio c'est le
diminutif oui on donne des petits
surnoms aux maladies on est bizarre
c'est le diminutif de poliomyélite c'est
une maladie causée par un virus qu'on
attrape généralement par voie orofécale
oraux c'est la bouche et fécale vous
voyez ce que c'est je pense donc on
avale un truc qui est souillé le virus
se développe dans nos intestins et il
finit par envahir le système nerveux et
devinez quoi bah il provoque des
douleurs et des paralysies j'ai pris
dachalo c'est la jambe droite qui est
touchée et qui se développera pas
correctement à 6 ans elle a mal elle
boîte et ça lui vaudra de la part de ses
petits camarades le surnom de Frida
jambe de bois
sont formidable finalement c'est
peut-être mieux de se contenter de
donner des surnoms maladies en fait
d'autant plus que ce surnom il est
cruellement prémonitoire vous verrez
tout à l'heure pourquoi voilà pour
l'enfance mais le destin n'en n'a pas
fini avec Frida à 18 ans elle est
victime d'un grave accident de bus elle
s'en sortira vivante mais avec des
fractures au niveau des côtes du bassin
de son pied droit qui était déjà malade
et de la colonne vertébrale à partir de
ce moment-là Frida Kahlo passera une
grande partie de sa vie soit allongée
soit en fauteuil roulant et en plus de
ces nouveaux handicap et de ses
nouvelles douleurs l'accident lui vaudra
aussi une autre séquelle il y a une
barre d'acier qui l'a transpercé en
entrant par son flan gauche et en
ressortant par son vagin elle va
raconter plus tard son accident en ces
termes le choc nous a projeté en avant
et une barre d'appui m'a transpercé
comme l'épée traverse un taureau avant
de conclure c'est comme ça que j'ai
perdu ma virginité autre conséquence
elle ne pourra jamais avoir d'enfant cet
accident terrible c'est une sorte de
déclencheur pour Frida Kahlo à la base
elle voulait être médecin elle était
même plutôt douée dans les matières conc
mais l'ironie du sort c'est à l'hôpital
qu'elle va commencer à peindre comme
elle peut pas quitter son lit ses
proches lui installe un petit dispositif
avec un miroir au plafond pour qu'elle
puisse peindre ses autoportraits les
autoportraits ça sera d'ailleurs une
grande partie de son œuvre par la suite
elle parlera par exemple un tableau
appelé la colonne brisée après une
énième opération de la colonne
vertébrale au total au cours de sa vie
elle en aura une trentaine et presque
autant de corset et si on regarde bien
sur cette toile on se rend compte
qu'elle a représenté son corps parsemé
de plein de petits clous et ben on peut
imaginer que c'est une manière de
symboliser une douleur dont on a déjà
parlé et dont elle souffrait parce qu'en
plus des douleurs liées à sa polio et à
ses multiples fractures Frida Kahlo
souffrait de douleur neuropathiques les
douleurs neuropathiques on en a déjà
parlé dans une vidéo que je vous invite
à aller voir ou à aller revoir mais chez
elle ces douleurs elles étaient causées
par les atteintes au niveau de sa moelle
épinière probablement en rapport avec
son spina-bifida sa fracture de la
colonne vertébrale et toutes les
opérations qu'elle a subi cette douleur
de manière générale elle peut prendre
plusieurs formes ça peut être des
sensations de brûlure à l'inverse des
sensations de froid ça peut être des
impressions d'avoir des décharges
électriques ou alors la sensation qu'on
vous plante des trucs pointus dans le
corps comme des clous par exemple ces
douleurs elles peuvent être très
difficile à supporter et Frida Kahlo
elle a passé sa vie à essayer de les
atténuer au point qu'elle est devenue
addict aux antidouleurs et à l'alcool et
peindra aussi d'autres tableaux inspirés
par la naissance et par ses fausses
couches alors oui là j'ai censuré les
tableaux on est sur Youtube et non
j'exagère pas l'or de la chaîne art
contemporain elle a fait aussi une vidéo
sur Frida Kahlo elle s'est fait Striker
donc elle a été obligée de faire la même
chose d'ailleurs je vous encourage
vivement à aller la regarder évidemment
elle elle parle de l'oeuvre de Frida
Kahlo et du coup c'est un pendant
vachement intéressant à la vidéo que je
vous fais là et donc oui en plus de tout
le reste Frida Kahlo a fait plusieurs
fausses couches vous souvenez la barre
d'acier qui l'a transpercé et ben elle a
fait des dégâts sur son passage et les
cicatrices à l'intérieur ça a donné des
adhérences et ça a provoqué ce qu'on
appelle un syndrome d'acherman c'est une
maladie qui et qui peut notamment avoir
comme conséquence de provoquer des
fausses couches alors il y a autre chose
dont je suis bien obligé de parler c'est
le système pileux de Frida Kahlo ces
poils son célèbre mono-sourcil et sa
moustache comme ça on pourra penser à ce
qu'on appelle un hirsutisme le fait
d'avoir plein de poils à cause d'une
surproduction d'hormones mal c'est ce
qu'avait les fameuses femmes à barbe
avant mais à vrai dire j'ai cherché et
j'ai rien trouvé à ce sujet concernant
Frida Kahlo ce qu'on sait par contre
c'est quel forcer un peu le trait elle
accentuait volontairement son
mono-sourcil et le crayon qu'elle
utilisait pour faire ça il a même été
exposé à Londres et pour samoussache
pareil et en plus de tout ça elle
prenait extrêmement soin que ça se voit
bien sur ses autoportraits mais pourquoi
elle faisait ça bah pour elle c'était
une façon de refuser à la fois les
injonctions à la beauté faites aux
femmes et les stéréotypes de genre et
aussi une façon de revendiquer une
sexualité libre et le respect de toutes
les orientations sexuelles c'était un
mono-sourcil militant et une moustache
féministe si vous voulez d'ailleurs
petite anecdote là dessus en 2002 la
réalisatrice Julie Taylor fait un film
sur Frida Kahlo qui décrit notamment une
relation toxiques avec son mari Diego
Rivera mais bon on va pas parler de lui
c'est pas lui qui nous intéresse c'est
Salma Hayek qui est aussi la
coproductrice du film qui va jouer le
rôle titre et elle a raconté par la
suite que l'autre coproducteur lui a
hurlé dessus parce que pour un carnet
Frida Kahlo elle avait un mono-sourcing
et une moustache l'argument du gars en
substance c'est tu as été engagée parce
que tu es belle et là tu es moche ce
producteur aussi cultivé que respectueux
c'était
Harvey Weinstein grand défenseur de la
cause féministe évidemment il a aussi
harcelé sexuellement Salma Hayek parce
que Frida Kahlo aurait adoré en août
1953 nouveau problème la gangrène gagne
de plus en plus de terrain sur la jambe
droite de Frida Kahlo sa jambe qui est
déjà bien abîmée par la polio et par
l'accident la gangrène c'est quand les
tissus d'un membre comme les muscles par
exemple bah ils commencent à mourir et à
se nécroser soit à cause d'une infection
soit parce que la circulation se fait
pas correctement pour éviter que ça se
propage trop et que ça la tue les
médecins finissent par réputé la jambe
droite de Frida Kahlo au niveau du genou
et la prophétie du surnom qu'on lui
avait donné quand elle était enfant se
réalise au départ Frida Kahlo elle donne
l'impression de prendre ça avec
philosophie et dire à même pourquoi je
voudrais des pieds alors que j'ai des
ailes pour voler mais en réalité son
amputation la plonge dans la dépression
elle prend de plus en plus de
médicaments à prendre de plus en plus
d'alcool ça sentait se dégrade et un an
plus tard une semaine après son 47e
anniversaire elle meurt d'une embolie
pulmonaire elle souffrait depuis
plusieurs semaines du pneumonie qui est
une infection au poumons elle était très
affaiblie une artère de ses poumons
c'est bouché et elle n'a pas survécu en
tout cas ça c'est la version officielle
parce que le petit fils de Diego Rivera
il a récemment affirmé que son
grand-père avait été Frida Kahlo à en
finir d'ailleurs elle-même elle a écrit
dans son journal qu'elle avait jamais
autant souffert de sa vie et qu'elle se
retenait de se suicider uniquement pour
ne pas faire souffrir son mari Frida
Kahlo a voulu être incinéré pour une
raison très personnelle qu'elle
expliquera avec ses mots même dans un
cercueil je ne veux plus jamais rester
couché ses proches de respecter sa
volonté enfin à moitié seulement parce
que c'est cendres elles ont été déposées
dans une urne qui représente son visage
et qui a été posée sur son lit avec
autour une espèce de pièce de tissu qui
donne vraiment l'impression qu'elle est
allongée là Saturne elle est toujours au
même endroit dans la maison où elle est
née où elle est morte et qui est devenue
depuis le musée Frida Kahlo toute sa vie
Frida Kahlo elle a peint sa douleur et
son combat pour se libérer de ses
prisons son corps et donc sa douleur
déjà sa condition de femme dans une
société mexicaine catholique et
patriarcale et toute forme d'oppression
en fait son engagement politique ça lui
a d'ailleurs permis de rencontrer
Trotski avec qui elle a eu une liaison
mais ça c'est une autre histoire
l'oeuvre de Frida Kahlo c'est son carnet
de santé bon ok pas seulement mais ça
faisait une conclusion stylée donc
laissez-moi tranquille voilà DTC c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui si ce nouveau
format carnet de santé ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les
commentaires j'en ferai d'autres je sais
pas encore à quel rythme mais j'en ferai
d'autres en attendant on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]